hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear Maureen and
Hank oh hello there this is a podcast
where today I Hank green and Maureen
Johnson answer your questions and
provide dubious advice and bring you all
of the latest news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon though I don't know if
Maureen has any AFC Wimbledon news do
you I barely know what balls are sports
balls sports balls but you're familiar
with listen do you uh have a poem for I
do oh that's great so you don't have any
AFC Wimbledon news but you will fulfill
John's role of a short poem
I certainly will um here's a short poem
for you blue jean baby la lady
seamstress for the band pretty eyed
pirate smile you'll marry a music man
ballerina you must have seen her dancing
in the sand and now she's in me always
with me tiny dancer in my hand and that
was of course part of tiny dancer
written by yes Bernie Taupin the man who
wrote lyrics to nearly ah it's it's an
extraordinarily high percentage of Elton
John's songs um that was beautiful as
beautiful a poem and somewhat unexpected
direction to go in
which I'm excited that yes because who
knows a bunch of short poems and is
pretentious enough to talk about them on
podcasts besides John Green no one no
one yeah zero zero people really so we
have some dear Hank and John updates the
first is that we have theme music now
thanks to gunnarolla Andrew gonna D who
you can see travel vlogging and making
music and being awesome at youtube.com
slash gonna roll ax with two N's and one
R and two L's and second John Green who
is that John of dear Hank and John is in
the pre-release madness of the Paper
Towns movie release
and he's gone he's I think he's in in
Brazil right now and he will not be here
he will not be at his house for the next
month and a half and his house is where
he records podcasts so we are going to
have a bunch of guest John's and the
first guest John as you probably have
guessed by now is Maureen Johnson can
you tell us about who you are more I'm
Maureen Johnson I am an author like John
unlike John I show up in do stuff um
this is now Hank this is the third time
that I've filled in for John because he
was simply too lazy or to show up sort
of know well don't make excuses Hank he
just didn't he did is he here no could
it be well I mean the first two times
were because somewhat not even that he
was having a baby someone else was
having a baby yes all right just someone
that he was have you know with that he
was closely related to through matrimony
well and I just want to say as a
footnote those two times I made videos
and he actually told me that the reason
he picked me to do it is that because I
am so bad at making videos he wanted to
make sure to pick someone that wasn't so
good that they wouldn't like hit them
better and then they would you know
really want him to come back
oh that's and that is it's a lovely
thought that John yeah that's such a
nice thing actually something he said to
me and you know what though I he was
right because I am not good at making
video well it does sound like something
John would say oh it is absolutely
something he said I you know and I I
also wrote a book with John um mm-hmm
I almost said called Paper Towns but
that's not it it's I don't know I don't
know what I do called let it snow so
yeah so I did so we have we've done that
together yeah and you do you have a tell
me about your jars
oh that's been a while um that is a
reference to people who follow me on
Twitter I spent a lot of time on Twitter
and I used to say that I would put
everybody who followed me inside a
little tiny jar and keep them with me
forever but I've read it's like on the
shelf behind you run out of space
sauron of jars they're still metaphor
you know that I still in spirit
everybody's in there but I've moved on
to other storage large large storage
containers shipping container on things
like what am I in a very special spot in
my heart but not I'm not in a jar or
separate Tupperware I have to wear small
small Tupperware yeah oh yeah I'm in a
nice one though not one of those ones
you throw away which frankly make me
angry
yeah yeah why is it I feel bad I get you
know like lunch meat now comes in this
Tupperware and you're like I now have
this and it's not very good but I have
it and it's clearly not just a bag or
it's not it's not a disposable container
and now I have this and I feel like I
have to clean it out and keep it but who
you know I I have to continue buying
more lunch meat and the only solution I
can see to this problem is is bla being
the lunch meat companies to to have more
sustainable packaging do you see any
solution aside from that one you know I
live in New York which is the land of
takeout and every time you get a
delivery you basically destroy the
planet every single time you get about
90 plastic containers hmm and then in
the end you're just like you know and
they're just for you know a handful of
rice but it's in like a huge very kind
of sturdy plastic container and you're
like oh I'm just gonna just get rid of
that I guess because I've got 600 of
them we should start a company a
business that just collects sturdy
plastic containers from people in New
York City and then resells them to
people who are normal in other other
states and and city you know what if
anybody was going to do that I think it
would be you because I believe you run
20 hundred businesses at this point well
that's the thing you have to you know if
you have an idea like that you cancel
like let nothing you got to move nothing
stand in your way somebody's gonna do
that especially now that we've said it
in the podcast and they're going to take
this idea and they're gonna make dozens
of dollars and then we'll we'll have
lost out on that opportunity you can be
a hundred air or a dozen air be
ambitious you know I always think of you
I don't know if you've probably read
catch-22 and there's a character day
major major that starts off sort of
selling eggs off the back of a truck at
the beginning of the book and by the end
he runs the war and you see that like
he's slowly like that's how I see you in
the input in a good way cuz he's a
little evil but not like that
you're like the good version of that you
want to know something about books that
I have noticed about myself yeah I would
like to learn something about books
I've been winging this a long time Hank
I was hoping somebody would would come
up to me and say that very sentence I
for a long time believed that if a book
was assigned in class that it was
definitionally an unpleasant thing to
read oh yeah sure I think a lot of
people think that and because of that
I've never read catch-22 ah
oh it's so good you should read it yeah
and and like I remember when I finally
read The Great Gatsby
after having you know cliff noted it in
Cliff's noted it in in high school I was
like this is a very good book kind of
surprised and I was like uh what why
didn't anybody tell me that this was
such a such a good book um I felt the
same way about Fahrenheit 451 which I
watch I read in in high school and I was
like you know ii hated every second of
it and i read it and i was like what a
what a fantastic piece of literature who
would have thought that this thing that
everyone is forced to read it is in fact
quite good and that is why they make us
read it it's true to some of these books
though can be confusing out of context
you know i read for example uh i've just
totally blanked on the title of Ernest
Hemingway's 1925 novel The Sun Also
Rises I believe is the one I'm searching
for and grasping for but I mean the one
of the major it just went away I was
about to really talk you know in a way
that was fancy like your brother and
then I suddenly forgot the title of all
books like I was like I don't know I was
reading some book and had some care I
just forgot everything I forgot
everything do you know that it was
published in 1925 no no no no 26 it was
torn super you don't know the name of
the book no it was the Sun Also Rises
okay it came to me as soon as I said the
year oh I was this kind of a kid and one
of the major Wow I I'm about to go right
into the territory that we start
but one of the major things you need to
know about this main character is that
he was injured during the war and is can
you say impotent sure yeah that's it I
just didn't well he is and that's
largely a huge part of the book which
was not something they were going to
explain to us in my Catholic all-girls
mmm high school yeah so you spend a lot
of time going why is this guy so angry
and why isn't he why won't he date this
woman he likes and why are all of these
things happen like that you know if they
leave out really important chunks of
information you may just spend a lot of
time going and this is this is awful to
get this character has no motivation I
don't understand it's very very strange
man just goes awry I don't know what
he's doing and I think something like
catch-22 you may need a lot of a good
bit of context it's it's not a book that
instantly or it's brilliant but it may
you know some of these things they don't
instantly arrive with you know all of
the which is why you know cliff notes
came around but they're people only read
the cliff notes and you know yes and the
circle of life continues also on John
song not by Bernie Taupin though I
believe those were Tim Rice lyrics wow
you know a lot about Elton John I know a
lot about Elton John but not about books
I don't know I know very very little
about books I've written some that's a
question all right so we uh you
mentioned earlier that you have several
times replaced John Green and in various
other US enterprises which is why I
wanted you to be the first guest John
here on dear Hank and John - John Amelia
has a question that's specific for you
she says dear Hank and marine what is it
like to be the actual John Green she is
referring hi Amelia you are referring to
the fact that the one of the first times
that when John went away for the first
time I made three videos for him which
almost killed me I mean I'm really not
good at this if I ever wanted to make
videos someone would actually have to
make the videos for me because I really
don't know what I'm doing I've never put
that on I like I shone light directly
into the camera like there I tried to
record an entire video
sitting next to a fountain so all your
years the thought I really stupid and I
did manage despite my ineptitude to
record a music video yes and I called
actual John Green and it is this sort of
riff on a Beastie Boy song called
sabotage and I just did it with it was
me and I gave the camera to a friend and
said follow me and we just we just made
this music video and my friend Jean
wrote the music and the answer to this
question is it's like I'm doing all the
work but without any of the perks so I'm
not hanging out with celebrities um you
know I'm not I'm not hanging out with
celebrities I think is one of the major
complaints I have and I truly believe
that even if they because would they
there's this possibility that let it
snow will be made into a movie and I
fully expect that articles will read
written by John Green and some randos
right and you'll just see us like you'll
see a hand in the corner of the photo in
the back and that'll be us so um but I'm
ok with that I'm actually fine with that
um he's a lovely guy is John he's lovely
yeah yeah but but being being the the
temporary replacement for him does it
leave you feel feeling unsatisfied it
doesn't you know what it's it's an honor
it is an honor and a privilege I mean
he's a nice piece you know what your
brother's a nice guy I'm glad you think
so
I I agree do you I do yeah I mean
sometimes he's my brother you know and
I'm like oh god shut up but he's a nice
guy oh we all think that but I mean it's
you know to be fair you know but I mean
he gets around your brother I mean you
know you don't I don't ever feel like
who you know if only there were just
more John Green articles in my life
right guy haha this guy alright enough
with this I have a question that is not
a question it's just my question who's
the who yeah do you think it's the most
famous person you've ever met probably
John Green really um oh now I'm thinking
I probably met a few well you know what
he's getting famous II I've met her a
little bit yeah he's getting kind of you
know he's in the time 100 and stuff like
that you know what I mean like like
every time I
read about you or your brother doing
something I'm always doing something
really wretched like looking for
something in the garbage or you know
Thank You VAX identity thrown away your
contact lens yeah and it is like well I
guess I could probably save it it was
like the day I have a really beautiful
necklace and I accidentally vacuumed it
up and I had to cut open a vacuum
cleaner bag oh yeah and search through
the the dust to find my necklace like
some sort of weird gem hunter and then
like John Green comes on NPR and is like
uh hello no he's like on The Today Show
in the background ha ha ha yeah that is
what it feels like but it's an it's in a
good way I don't think I'd be good at
those things so I'm kind of glad he he's
yeah I I'm super glad that I don't have
to do with that that stuff either and
it's it is a weird thing to have my
brother showing up in those strange
places but um but yeah I it's I do not
find myself envious of it I I met
will.i.am this this weekend and in
France and so that and and like before
then I really wasn't sure if like it was
John or if it was Wil Wheaton or if it
was brent spiner or like any of the
various other like famous nerds that
I've met who are famous for being nerds
like I've met lots of those people but I
meant will.i.am and I'm like you're more
famous than any of the famous nerds that
I that I hang out with yeah you know
that's the thing real famous people have
that kind of you know otherworldly glow
I mean I did I had a I worked on a weird
conference once in Vegas where I met the
first George Bush and Jay Leno in the
space of like moons three hours oh yeah
well George Bush is definitely more
famous than John Green probably Hey but
yes he was a president it's John not the
president I'm not sure all right
you're probably Alec he's on the phone
to the president you know it's it's it's
ridiculous but it's actually reached the
point now where I just sort of assumed
that I'm gonna see you know as I said to
John when the fault in our stars came
out that
they didn't project the image of the
okay okay unto the face of the moon then
he was a failure and it didn't happen so
he failed we're gonna stop talking about
John he's not here this isn't about him
yeah this is yeah why are we talking
about John he's like a ghost he's
haunting us yeah gross
it's like a gross smelly ghost do you
want to give us a question ask Maureen
how do you live in London and America do
you have some kind of weird dual
citizenship and allow me to ask this how
do I get this I don't live in London in
America I only live in America but you
are always going and for a while I mean
this isn't the case anymore but for a
while you were you were in London like
every other week yes yeah and there's a
reason for that and it you know it's it
seems like I might be a spy yes sighs
hey I am I am a spy you're not allowed
to say that as a spy just to be clear if
for the first like a spy lesson number
one is is never say it seems like I
might be a spy like don't just don't
bring that up
yeah oh well but anyway sorry you've
ruined your spy status so you're not a
spy anymore I go to I go to England
still my partner is English and so I for
many years we lived in two separate
places so I would go there he would come
here but I would go there more because
my job is weirder and I'm a writer so I
you know I don't have to go to an office
sometimes I go to offices and they say
please leave and I'm yeah can I stay and
I stay there and like I didn't like to
the closets and stuff and I can stay
there for a while sometimes before they
find me but in general I'm not supposed
to go to offices so but he has to go to
one every day because he makes video
games so they make him they make him go
to an office and now he lives here and
he goes to an office but you didn't have
any like green card problems with that
they didn't try to kick you out of the
country they didn't try to kick me out
of the country I everything you know I
heard you know each time which is good
and they did start asking me more and
more personal questions hmm like you
know how serious are you about this
relationship really yeah the customs guy
was like yeah so how serious are you
about your relationship yes I'm not
doing anything after work look well yeah
he's accustomed I mention he
customs guys well um but he ya know they
would ask they ask things like this and
they ask you especially if you're a
writer you get us all kinds of weird cuz
it's a dumb job to have and I've gotten
lots of questions like your writer what
do you write books one of the first
question have I heard of you mmm no
since you're holding my passport looking
at me looking at my name is looking at
my photo and saying do I know you is
probably no and one guy when I went back
to New York and I was really jet-lagged
and half-asleep and it was like in my
mind 4:00 in the morning and he said so
do you write good books and I was like I
don't know and he's like what do you
mean you don't know you should be more
confident say you write great books I
was like what and he's like say you're
right great books and he wouldn't stamp
my passport until I said I was great
writer so it's not just an immigration
service it's also a self-esteem yes
there's self-confidence boosters and and
also now you have customs certified by
the United States of America a stamp
that says you are a great writer I say
smiley face I think that's what that
means it's a smiley face on a book yeah
I'm not a hundred percent sure I was in
immigration I was really tired but yeah
so that's that's the answer to that one
all right um Hannibal asks dear Hank and
John I'm a high school student and I'm
being passive-aggressively pressured by
my parents to get a job for the summer
personally I'd like to get a job so that
I can save up to move out in a couple of
years so I asked you oh wise people I
found on the Internet
what are some good methods or strategies
for finding a job if it helps some of my
skills include video editing a short
story writing a knowledge of how
computers work also competence but
that's sort of but that's sort of
necessary for working I would I would
really argue with that last one I have a
lot of thoughts about this do you do you
I would say that the number one most
important thing on the list of things
that you just listed was competence like
like that's the one
because you're not going to as a high
school student you're not probably not
going to find a high skilled job in the
in the writing or video editing areas
though I concur egde you to try but just
being generally competent and thought
that's gonna that's going to be the
thing that gets you the job at the
entry-level position yeah I've had I've
had a lot of jive had so many jobs I
mean I went to school for I went to art
you know art school basically I was I
was an English major and then I went and
got an MFA in New York so I was a
theatre and writing student in an MFA
program which means that I was broke and
had to do anything and I had a couple
and I'd moved to New York which is just
the most expensive place you can live so
my policy was I would do any job and I
had really dumb weird jobs and I walked
into New York without a job and I said I
am going to get the weirdest job I can
find and I got it through life which
honestly you shouldn't do but you know
you shouldn't do it if like you're a
surgeon but you can maybe do it if it's
like well it's really it's about like do
you know enough like are you empathetic
enough to know the lie to tell yes and
if you can tell a really good lie that's
not going to get anybody in trouble and
it's not gonna hurt anybody then you're
displaying a kind of competence in in
communicates a communication skill yes
lying don't yeah don't lie except it
turns out that the only way to get a
restaurant job in New York is to lie and
say you've worked there before so you
have to say of course and so I made a
resume with all of these restaurants in
England because I had studied there
knowing that because at the time there
was no like Skype or anything and
knowing that they wouldn't call mmm and
so I had this because I'd worked some of
them I just really extended the times
and then I fully made up about three of
them but I walked in with an air of
total confidence but I want to also
explain that I was trying to get a
waitressing job in a haunted house
restaurant so you know I was not trying
to get a job in Eric traffic control I
was literally trying to it was the most
amazing job I've ever had because that
place was loaded down it's just closed
I'm so sad it was loaded down with
microphones and video cameras and little
things on the wall like animatronic
skeletons and stuff so we so people
upstairs could spy on all the customers
God and we knew what they were doing so
we knew if they were complaining and
things because we could say like turn on
the rhinoceros on table 42 and then the
right I go yeah no I have a lot of
stories about this that seems that seems
illegal
oh no you knew you went in knowing that
all of the things on the walls were cuz
they talked they'd the thing was it was
fun cuz she'd go you'd go there because
it would suddenly spring alive and
suddenly the skeleton would talk to you
right it would like respond to something
you were saying yeah and it was supposed
to catch you off-guard like hey give me
a fry and they'd really good so scary
but also the skeleton was listening to
see if you were going to send back those
appetizers I love that so we would kind
of know like you know 42 is gonna send
back their appetizers and like it was
the weirdest dump I encourage having
lots of stupid jobs don't worry if you
get like a dumb job or what seems like a
gross job or I've had so many dumb and
gross jobs they are the best jobs you
can possibly have
I miss waitressing cuz it's so like you
had to learn to read people really
quickly you had to learn to kind of live
on a day-to-day like the money I took
home in my pocket was what I lived on
and I really had to scramble to earn my
money and like do a good job and that I
learned a lot of people skills and some
of the best stories I have are from my
kind of dumb you know weird like picking
up garbage at Sesame please what's the
job I had I watched someone punch Grover
once that's something I saw was was
Grover it was there a hand in Grover was
or was Grover animatronic no like a
person was inside of a giant costume oh
he Jayant Grover yeah people regularly
hit costume characters it is terrible I
was a mascot I was the high school
mascot at my high school Lily the
Wildcat and I I would get beat by little
children they like you know it was an
expensive suit and I was told to like
protect the suit with my life and not
let anyone hurt the suit and when they
would like pull the tail of the suit I
like what are you gonna do hit a child
like I can't communicate I'm wearing a
wildcat costume and so I would sad to
you know like wag my wild cat finger at
them and that was all I could do yeah I
I did not like that people take out a
lot of aggressions on costume characters
I
once when I worked for theater festival
they called me at five in the morning
and they said morning get down here
because the guy we hired is too big so
you're small come over and get in the
costume and they put me in a Cat in the
Hat costume that you saw out of the neck
so it like had another head on top of my
head and then they just you're supposed
to have someone with you but they just
sent me out on the streets of
Philadelphia and 100 degree temperatures
and I remember wandering into the road
and I couldn't see where I was going and
I walked into the side of a building so
you know these are the times I cherish
so yeah go out there you know what just
go out there ask people about jobs I
think it's fine to sort of go into
places you're interested in or just mmm
you know there's like a little shop in
your town or whatever like go in and
just start asking people if they're
hiring and you know that's that's really
how I think it's done I I I did that to
get jobs as well and I found a very
terrifying to like walk into a place and
be like okay accept me make me your
person and and choose pick me but yeah
that it's normal they're used to it and
you may have this feeling when you walk
in the door cuz you know like where I
lived there a lot of this store called
Wawa which is a convenient smart and
when I went in normally I didn't think
about it but when I went in to ask for a
job it suddenly seemed like I was
walking into the White House like
suddenly will seem like oh I have to be
on my best behavior I'm in a Wawa you
know like it suddenly seems all
different that's normal don't worry
about that just like be like oh I'm
getting into a different mindset just
ask them if they have an application I
have another question this one is from
Nick Nick says dear Hank and Maureen
would you rather have the ability to
turn everything you touch into Dwayne
the rock Johnson or have every song you
listen to sound like smash mouths all
star this is you okay
this is dark well the thing that I
noticed about this question it said it
says that either you have the ability to
turn everything you touch into joining
the rock Johnson or you have to have
every song you listen to sound like
Smash Mouth sorrel star and if it's the
ability if I can chew
then I would definitely choose the
Dwayne the rock Johnson power because
basically that changes my life not at
all I will just choose to never exercise
that ability no I got to go the other
way why are you afraid it's gonna you're
gonna accidentally turn someone in and
join the rock Johnson well one for sure
I am for sure I am like I'm going you
know it's always that time that you're
not paying attention and you're gonna
turn something into Dwayne the rock
Johnson it's just it's gonna be your MA
and you've done it and she's the rock
however so you kind of ruined the world
because you know what the rock is great
but what's so great about the rock is
that there's one of him you know like if
it was too many rocks yeah yeah but the
only person suffering with the second
one and I do degree this is this is
suffering is you if every song you hear
just sounds like smashmallows all-star
well the thing is I like that song but I
still wouldn't want every song I
listened to to sound like it that song
is a really like notoriously terrible
ear worm I mean that is mm-hmm
just even I've said it now and that's
that's two weeks gone well have you ever
listened to Neil Sasser egas mouth
sounds
no well next time you're on a road trip
or on an airplane it's really great road
trip music actually I thought that would
be my suggestion if you're ever on a
road trip
download mouth sounds by Neil says
serega it is a mix what do they call it
went a mashup mix that's what it's
called
and it's just wonderful like it's called
a mashup mix whatever I don't it's it's
a mixes of mashups bunch of phrases
together what do you call what a kiss
called a mix mash a monster mash a mix
monster mash it's definitely a mix mash
Lentini is it a and it's it is allstar
is central to it and and it is really
really pleasant to listen to and and and
hilarious that song was featured in
every movie made between like 1995 and
1998 as well I yeah I think that the
folks from Smash Mouth did okay that
they actually even a pie remember this
vividly they even appear in a movie
place in rat-race it's in that race at
the end of the race
concert they're all forced to go at the
end of this terrible movie they're all
forced to go to a Smash Mouth concert
it's not a terrible movie but it's not a
terrible I love rap I love rat race
uh I do like it too but the actual
events are tired like like having to do
all this stuff and at the end you also
have to go to a Smash Mouth concert they
seem so happy though the problem is they
have to give the money away actors
actors have to like that oh I'm so happy
to be dancing around all-star hey no
you're an all-star put your pants on you
know it's in everybody's head and a head
and also we can't we can't put this
podcast up because you sing all-star so
you've ruined the copyright no I'm
kidding it's fine sing all you want well
good cause I have a whole songbook here
I just let me go to my piano do you want
to give us another question I do as soon
as I scroll down now I know I'm ready
dear Hank and John this is from Catlin
considering humans cannot see every
color
well news to me I have that new Apple
screen that shows all the colors even
the ones that oh right you can't see
what happens to all the unseeable colors
do we just see them as white black or
clear do you think scientists will find
a way to genetically modify our eyes to
see those colors seems like it is a
question for me oh I don't know anything
about science so so what Maureen was
surprised to hear is that there are
colors that we can't see that's not
really true because the word color is is
is almost is like by definition a thing
that we can see but there are but but
like scientifically a color is a
wavelength of light it is being detected
by our eyes it's a visual representation
of a certain wavelength of radiation and
there are far more wavelengths of
radiation than the ones that we can see
the visible light portion of the
electromagnetic spectrum is very small
and and so there are there are lots of
wavelengths that are outside of what the
receptor in our eyes is actually able to
to like detect and and it will trigger
an action potential so action potential
being the the neuronal
signal that gets sent to your brain and
interpreted as color so since we only
have receptors we have like the rods and
the cones we only have receptors for
certain wavelengths
there are wavelengths outside of that
and those do not trigger the action
potential and so if you were in a room
with a light bulb that shined only light
in that undetectable by us frequency we
you would appear to be in a dark room
you would not you would not detect
anything unless it was a really high
energy and it was like actually ionizing
something in your eyeballs and making
you see glowing in which case you have
other things to worry about like you're
probably going to get cancer so we see
unseeable colors as black and as for
whether or not genetically genetic
modification could allow us to someday
see those colors yeah that's the thing
that could happen but it would not be a
huge benefit partially because the
majority of the light of the radiation
in in and around us is in the visible
spectrum and that's because most of the
other radiation is either absorbed by
the atmosphere or not emitted by the Sun
in the first place so the reason we can
see in the visible spectrum this like
narrow band is because that's actually
where most of the radiation around us
lies there's some in the ultraviolet and
some of the infrared as well but we
mostly don't it's not there isn't that
much of that sort of radiation though
there is enough that you should wear
sunscreen I just want to add the other
day I went to a 3d movie but I didn't
know it I just thought I was buying
tickets to a regular movie and when I
got there they were like you went 3d
glasses for your 3d movie and I was like
oh I didn't even realize I bought
tickets to a 3d movie and I just sort of
want to complain that I think that
sometimes they should make it more clear
because you don't always want to go see
3d movie sometimes is that part of the
answer does that does that kind of are
you aware that I sell a product that
allows you to watch 3d movies in 2d I am
aware that that was one of the first
times I said Hank is an actual proper
genius well thank you very much and at
when I was going to see my 3d movie
where I lost my 3d glasses three times
on the way it was a weird afternoon and
there was this Paper Towns poster there
that had the disappearing Margo mm-hmm
in it so I was like oh this whole movie
theaters doing crazy crazy things to my
eyes today and that's something about
ice yes eyes it has to do with eyes it's
not the same thing that uses a
completely different set of phenomena I
was really annoyed at Apple when they
were like we have made this computer
with these these colors and this screen
is so good that you literally will not
be able to see or perceive the changes
we've made because they are too good for
your fragile human meat sacks I had not
I did not hear that oh yeah when they
came out with the Retina display they
maybe they didn't because it was Oscar
my partner who is this who is the
science nerd of our household and was
like you know some of these changes we
will never be able to perceive they're
like have to upgrade human bodies before
before people will be able to enjoy the
upgrade to their phone we are a bunch of
dumb meat sacks with eyes are just
basically big jelly balls and we are not
good enough for these products all right
give us another question marine Sophia
asks dear Hank and John I am terrified
that I will finish high school go to
college get a job get married have some
kids wrinkled up and die the average
progression of adulthood terrifies me I
want to make a spectacular impact on the
world but it seems like those dream jobs
where your life makes a difference to
the world are hard to come by is it
impossible to hope my life does not
become normal if not how should I go
about making that dream a reality
that's a great question I will say that
it's real easy to look at the at like
the very sort of surface level things
that we know about the people around us
and the people we like see the grocery
store and the stories that we sort of
imagine about all of the folks that live
in the world and and just assume that
their lives are boring and that there's
that they have this like typical
progression of life and it's just like a
movie that you've already seen and
you're like well I know I know how this
ends so why even bother but in fact
that's
not how anybody's life is and I think
that most people maybe even all people
have lots of weird spectacular things
that happen in their lives and
contribute greatly to the human endeavor
that's that that my yeah so my take on
that is uh is that you will that my take
on that is that those those ways to live
your life and not just jobs but general
life things that make a difference to
the world aren't aren't hard to come by
and it is not impossible to believe that
your life will have an impact and in
fact it it will likely happen even if
you aren't trying but it is good to be
driven and tried to have those impacts
because you know it will drive you to do
more interesting and weird things I had
this this was this question was
basically my fear through all of high
school I was not even fear I was just
very determined that I was not going to
you know that that wasn't going to
happen to me and what Hank just said I
agree with a million I mean my mother
for example is a nurse and she's like oh
my job is so run-of-the-mill and just a
nurse but no it's not what she does is
extraordinary I mean one of my mother's
days is like so much more I mean she's
someone severs a finger she's getting a
finger out of a machine she's like
resuscitating somewhat like she's doing
all of these things then when she's
getting a finger out of a machine yes
they have like a vending machine of
fingers they do have that okay they have
that now they have those now don't you
have those we have those in news it's
like it's like those new things that
like will fix your espresso just the way
you want it it's like just program and
you need the finger you need we just eat
fingers here um know where my mother
works I don't want to say too much about
this that she works in a a school
setting where there are mushy there's
machinery and she has had to do things
like Oh get severed fingers out and
she's had to do she does a lot of right
kind of extreme stuff and I think what
she does is so exceptional and so
amazing and I'm just so and I really am
in awe like of what she does but I I
went to you know I I went to a Catholic
girl school and they made us take a
class called marriage and it was taught
by a nun and that first of all right
there I seem to be the humor of that was
not lost on me at the time and I spent
every single day sitting in marriage
class taught by an unjust staggered by
where I was for as far as I was
concerned all of high school was just
someone trolling me and defacing my
marriage book just making fun of
everybody in the pictures it um I would
just say don't you know these things
that seem ordinary are truly when they
happen to exceptional and just you you
kind of make your own luck and you make
your own chances so you have to sort of
not be afraid to veer from the path a
little bit um you know you have to that
that ability to kind of step out and say
I don't really care if I look stupid I
don't really care if I have to seem like
I have to prove anything to anybody that
just takes a little bit of courage
sometimes and sometimes you have to do
stuff that you're like I'll never get
out of here I'll do lots of dumb jobs
forever and that's not true like I you
you can you sometimes have to work your
way to these places that are the more
unusual jobs you don't sort of land
there overnight
either so don't worry if it does it
happen like overnight because I think a
lot of people like I am 21 and not a
celebrity yet I'm gonna this awful like
no yeah my interest free you're fine the
other thing to remember is like that
that getting married and having some
kids like those are really remarkable
things those are some remarkable things
yeah
and when you do that you can get someone
else to make your videos for you
what do you mean like I should have kids
so that so that my child will make my
videos for me well you could do that I
meant that you know your brother Oh John
I would never let John make my videos
for me he's not even that good at it oh
that I'm not even gonna bother to
correct you or like go back cuz that is
just just boom you just you just Hank
stamp that you're like Dan yeah boom you
drop the mic you walked away that way
that's justice why this is
you're the more popular it's just
brotherly love yeah the thing the thing
is the nice thing about John being much
more popular than me is that I can say
mean things about him and it doesn't
seem that mean because like he's John
Green I'll tell you a true story about
cuz he's a lovely guy one time we I was
out with John and his editor and for
some reason we decided to see if we
could get into a who could punch John
harder in the arm contest which he fully
allowed he's like go ahead and so Julie
punched him in the arm and I punched him
in the arm and we were like who did it
harder and then he was like thinking
about it we just kept kind of hitting
him in the eye and he was fine with it
he seemed to was like oh well you know
it was kind of a tie and cuz he's just a
lovely person oh god he's like a gentle
giant you're both very tall to all of
the people out there if you ever see
John Green don't punch him in the arm
don't punch him in the arm even if he
lets you because he looked really sad
and I think we may have like kind of
bruised his arm like we were not trying
to hurt him we just sort of wanted to
see which one of us could hit harder you
weren't trying to hurt him you were just
hurting him I also don't hit very hard
honestly like I I am NOT
I don't possess a great deal of arm
strength Julie however I think does mmm
and that that must have heard I think on
my side there was probably not a lot of
you know I I'm the person who can never
get a jar open I'm you know I'm not you
can easily defeat me in arm wrestling
and other arm sports so yes right we got
but I think it's important Hank I think
it's very very important that when this
podcast comes out no matter what happens
you have to tell him there was a huge
spike in popularity right he went away
and when I okay when I filled in okay
well I think what we have to do is we
had like in order for that to happen
people like that has to be true so
people should tell all of their friends
to download the podcast even if they're
not going to listen to it oh absolutely
but also to tell them to listen to it
because aren't we just so charming you
guys are very charming well I mean you
and me i I'm not gonna speak to that I'm
not gonna speak to it Hank I know that
you're charming I've seen your videos
I've seen you in person I've seen you
guys are very charming people you're
nice people that's why people like you
you don't you you're not going to accept
your own charm I don't have any proof of
it I have a scientific mind your name
alright uh a mom asks dear Hank and John
so it's Ramadan at the moment a month in
the Islamic year when people fast during
daylight hours but my mom has made the
call that I need nutrition and can't
fast so I've decided to give up music
instead music is in my blood I am a pop
chart geek so I need time fillers that
don't have music first I apologize for
our theme music I hope I didn't prevent
you from listening to the podcast or
brewing anything for you second I think
that this is a really cool idea to
extend the spirit of Ramadan outside of
the constraints of your situation and I
think that not listening to music is
interesting thing like in general not do
it like not doing something that is like
sort of your thing for a while to like
see what other things there are that
might be your things I think that's cool
idea so Maureen any any things for an
item you know this it's a hard because I
feel like I don't have the the
qualifications the knowledge to answer
this question but um I would say that I
hope that during this time you are not
approached with this whole question
about whether or not all the songs you
hear sound like I'll start by smashmouth
well that's not actually wouldn't be a
problem
at this point because there are there
are no songs that she's hearing yeah I'm
just saying if anybody approaches you
that full stop like don't don't agree to
it right okay how in general if if it's
a if it's a would you rather always make
sure first that we're talking
hypotheticals here and that you're not
actually going to bestow me the power to
turn anything a touch into Dwayne the
rock Johnson which of course being that
I like my foot is currently touching my
leg I might accidentally turn myself
into Dwayne the rock Johnson which would
be really confusing for me and my wife
and all of my viewers on YouTube it's
the first thing that would happen I
yeah like you just you know go to move
your hair or something or your sleep you
know and then suddenly you wake up and
you're join the rock Johnson and then
you're done
like it's just done the huge problem
with me becoming Dwayne the rock Johnson
would be I would immediately like I
would exercise the current amount so I
like over the course like I would not
start to exercise rock level exercise I
would just diminish in size until I was
like the sad skinny rock and everybody
be like oh there's Hank he's like he
looked like he's genetically identical
to Dwayne the rock Johnson but he looks
so very very soft
they call him gravel or something or
pebble some sort of 2 million to me hey
Hank the pebble Johnson Hank this the
the the small stone just mud that's it's
just a tiny tiny rocks in water clay
yeah fish gravel well I respond to this
question I would say podcasts for one
you listen to one right now there are a
lots more and they do have a theme music
but I think that's not in the spirit of
what you're trying to do here there are
many podcasts that I would suggest you
listen to there's actually a really
interesting podcast in which they
dissect songs that probably would not be
in the spirit of what you're trying to
do but there's lots of podcasts about
lots fascinating things there's also
lots of youtube videos and movies and
and you go see some stand-up comedy
maybe a like that's meeting dating
reading but you can also go dating but I
mean reading yeah yeah reading is just I
don't I don't know it spend your time
dating just date everything seems it
seems more more than anything else that
just seems very tiring yeah exhausting
call up Dwayne the rock Johnson and see
if he'll go on a date with you that
that's one thing you can know would it
take do you thing to get to get the rock
to go on a date with you marine like I
don't think it would happen for me but
but for you if you wanted to like really
badly go on a date with between the rock
Johnson what would you what would you do
oh that is not something I've thought
about
I imagine I would have to be he seems
like a nice person he does seem I got
very nice it seems like a night so I
think I'd have to do something kind of I
would have to get in the news for
something like rescuing a bunch of
puppies okay you know what I mean like I
want to be somebody you know you need
something like that oh you're the person
that rescued all those dogs from the hot
air balloon like you know that you'd and
then everyone would I hang it you know
it's like Sully Sullenberger the guy who
landed the plane on the Hudson like I
yeah he could probably date the rock if
you wanted to I would love to he is my
imaginary boyfriend I'm always like you
landed a plane on the Hudson like you're
the best Sully Sully could you know
Sully can do anything he wants okay so
he's a great man all the clubs you know
the velvet rope comes back for Sully
right I just don't think that maybe
that's his his bag he seems like he's
just above all of that yeah I think he
just spends his nights doing good deeds
yeah I was trying to get I would try to
lower the rock with good deeds right
okay no I that's a that's a that's a
good thought I actually have a friend
who's met the rock so you're only two
degrees I'm practically there I should
make it like my yeah I mean I'd I'd
isn't he's probably married he's
probably married I know nothing about
the rocks personal life hmm
fact now I don't know but he seemed like
he'd be married cuz he said oh he is oh
he's not married he's divorced in 2008
well then I better get to work I better
look for a earning you know puppy
orphanage or something okay
that's how I would do it I think I think
it is always good to just do a bunch of
good deeds and then people will look at
you and see so you've done good deeds
for the right reasons but also people
will look at you go hey there's a
do-gooder yeah and and the rock will say
you know you and I we we like to do some
of the things same things making the
world a better place maybe we should go
get a drink I would or another thing I
could do is like have get stuck under a
really anything thank you just make sure
you're nearby the rock yeah and you get
a rock a really
I rock that only the rock can lift yes
stuck on you yeah and then once he saved
you you've you like I feel indebted to
you I need to buy you a drink it's super
complicated but it would probably work
no that is a great great plan you just
have to kind of you have to really stay
pretty close to the rock and you have to
be willing to put up with a certain
amount of grievous bodily harm pressure
you know like this is terrible but in
the Salem witch trials one of the people
accused was pressed to death oh and
apparently his last words were more
weight ah and I believe that that is
possibly the situation you might end up
in while trying to lure the rock wall
right under a rock uh-huh you feel like
he's not paying attention yet he does
not see me in another plight yeah it
can't be like a paperweight ask to be
like something out of Roadrunner like a
rock what if it was just the rock what
if the rock fell on top of you that's
what you need to do you need to you need
to be standing in front of the rock has
someone tripped the rock and the rough
Rock lands on you and then he feels bad
for hurting you and then he takes you
out for the drink I think another thing
you lay on the ground in front of you
lay on the ground and wait for the rock
to come by so if I come to New York City
tomorrow will I just see you laying on
the sidewalk yeah but that's that's what
I do I mean that's not unusual no that's
not unusual at all um that's not unusual
uh that's that's just you know so
yesterday if you come over that's yeah
you I'll tell you where to find me
because I could be in a number of
different place number of different
places on the ground just on the ground
okay sure well in the meantime Maureen
Johnson do you have any news to share
from us from AFC Wimbledon because
John's not here to give us that
fascinating just obscure football trivia
you know at living with an English
person I occasionally hear words about
football that's all I have to say about
that
give me some football
it's then uh you say things like come on
England he says that a lot what does he
say when he's sad about it uh he just
sort of makes a noise like ah just
pretty typical really yeah yeah he image
people I will say this vetting those
people English people don't give you a
straight answer about anything so it's
hard to get and you English people if
you're listening you know they're like
yeah she's got a point because if you
say something to ask her like do you
want cheese on your sandwich he won't
say yes I'd like cheese or no I don't
want cheese he'll say the thing about
cheese is and then you'll get like a 9
to 10 minute lecture on cheese and
you'll be like great do you want cheese
and they'll be like well you know we
can't really know anything about cheese
truly and they will not sort of tell you
ever just forever you're just you'll go
insane trying to get a straight answer
but football is one of the few things
where they do seem to kind of really
give you their their true emotions
I believe it exists in order for English
people to just say yes or no in a kind
of clear way like yes I am happy you
kick that ball into that net no I am
disappointed with your actions to kick
the ball into the net you are failure to
me in your country well I feel like
actually I may have learned more from
your football news than from John's just
because I really do need a base level of
instruction here I feel like I'm jumping
in it way too high a level when John
talks about AFC Wimbledon you know it is
beautiful I have watched the World Cup
and I was like this seems like it would
be you know a good sport to know
anything about but I don't I don't know
anything about any sports to watch them
truthfully I am that horrible person who
just doesn't just doesn't know I feel
like I'm sort of missing a gene or
something like I can tell it's really
good and fun but I think it's okay I
think you got other things that you can
that you can be excited about and and do
with your time but I just like to be
excited about more stuff well do you
want to be excited about Mars I would
never go to Mars Hank no I agree I would
also never go to Mars
okay I'm perfectly prepared to be
excited about it as long as I don't have
to go there okay in in Mars news this
week NASA is developing a tiny
ultralight plane that could
packed onto the next Mars mission with
the ability to fly up 20 up to 20 miles
before for a landing on the surface of
Mars after the the rover portion of the
mission was deployed it would be folded
up inside of the ballast that's ejected
before the rover lands and it would be
able to deploy after landing it would
weigh 2.6 pounds so a tie it's very
small and it's like two feet long and it
would be able to fold up into a CubeSat
configuration it wouldn't add any cost
to a future mission and they're
currently testing similar configurations
here on earth where there's a lot more
atmosphere and a lot more gravity so
they'd have to change the thing a little
bit and also a big problem is that the
earth version navigates with GPS but
there is no GPS system on Mars yet
because you need all the satellites to
make GPS system so they have to develop
a new kind of navigational system if
they want to fly the first plane on Mars
and the next Mars mission that NASA will
be sending which might launch as soon as
2020 - do you think they're really going
to do the thing where they send the 10
or 20 people on the one-way mission to
Mars well that's not NASA that's a step
that slike a private thing are they but
do you think that they're no I do not
think that they're going to do it I
think that I do not think that they're
going to be able to get together the
kind of money that would be necessary to
do that I don't think it's just shy
initially they have the more people than
they can that they know what to do as
lots of people want to do it I don't
know why no one will want to pay for it
the only reason so many people want to
do it is because there are so many
people so if you start if you have any
preposterous idea you can find 11 people
who will do it as long as you have the
money to pull it off so people yeah
people like I want to be the first
person to die on Mars that way people
will remember me and I won't have to go
through the stupid progression of life
where I just graduate from high school
and then college and then get married
and have kids and then wrinkled up and
die I want to be a Mars man but you know
and some some people have have to get
over that and be alright with the fact
that they're going to die here on earth
like everyone else so far well that's it
that's a cheerful that's how we always
we always like to bring it back around
to death here on dear
Oh John well can I bring him back to
life because I watched our talk with
Neil deGrasse Tyson the other day and
I'll tell you but for two reasons one
cause it's great and two because my
dog's Zelda loves watching Neil deGrasse
Tyson on television she loves him and
will come from anywhere in the house to
sit there and watch Neil deGrasse Tyson
and that is true she she just sits there
staring adoringly at him and sometimes
will get up on the and once knock to the
television over in her attempts to get
at Neil deGrasse Tyson and kiss him and
it's only Neil deGrasse Tyson she knows
the sound of his voice
she knows his face and she will come
from any corner of the house to get near
him but I was watching that with the dog
who was thrilled and they were talking
about the Mars missions and one of the
people on Startalk was said we will
probably know within the next 20 years
whether or not theirs will get the soil
samples and we will know whether or not
there's life on Mars mmm and it does
that excite you are you a betting on
this are you like yes I think there is
um I don't think so that the getting a
negative is very hard so like knowing
for sure that there isn't life on Mars
so what really they're saying is that
it's very likely that there is or was
and that we will end that that if if it
was if it was widespread across the
planet which it probably was if there
was life at all then then it will be
pretty easy for us to figure that out we
just have to we have to be able to do a
lot of a lot more science than is easy
to do remotely so having a sample sent
back to us or being there to do the
science it's kind of necessary and
having a sample sent back to us is a lot
easier than being there to do it because
it's not easy to live on Mars
okay follow-up question are there ghosts
on Mars no all right you seem pretty
sure
okay you seemed really sure about that
yeah I mean I feel I feel pretty
confident that there aren't any ghosts
um ours well I guess we'll find out
well we you they have to go up there
with you know like the ghost hunting
shows have to go up there with their you
know I felt a cold spot
and you know the there's a breeze in the
room I want to see Ghost Hunters on Mars
then I'll know for sure tank then I'll
know for sure I have a scientific mind
well you apparently are just ready to
discount this whole whole just of whole
cloth just say I don't believe it but
not me show me show me those
electromagnetic readings with the little
cookie thing then I'll be sure okay I
don't think you're thinking like a
scientist saying I don't know how you do
scishow with like sloppy sloppy
reasoning like that exists eeeh I have a
very closed mind apparently when it
comes to whether or not they're ghosts
in a place where there have never been
people well I guess we'll find out do
you think maybe they're they're like a
little like Martian life-form ghosts
like if they were like one celled
animals there's or whatever they would
be I think there is literally a show
called Space Ghost
oh I do believe that there is a Space
Ghost
oh so the story changes it's just it's
just he's not a ghost
he's Space Ghost isn't he no face his
name is space car he but he's not a
ghost it's a it's a metaphorical name
he's a superhero he's a he's a fighter
Space Ghost oh sorry sorry Oh your
highfalutin talk is not impressing you
know it just doesn't seem like you know
very much about Space Ghost
I met Space Ghost the voice of Space
Ghost and I got him to sign my wallet
and he was very kind to me I met him at
an anime convention when I was in
college did you meet the voice of brac
no I didn't well then this story isn't
so great is it I really do like brac a
lot yeah it was prank it was good any
angry mantis yeah uh what was his name
mmm big fan huh mm-hmm I hear the typing
in the captain goes Warrick
Sarek yeah all right I was trying to
moan over the sound of the typing that's
that's always a good that's always a
good thing to do on a podcast it's just
moan to cover up your typing noises yeah
well that means we have to we have to
deceive the audience somehow Maureen the
magic of theater and with and with that
it feels like it is about time to wrap
up is there are there any final words
that you would like for the audience of
dear Hank and John obviously I've
enjoyed being here and I hope that I
hope it's been okay know that John is
coming back you know in a while it's
gonna be a while I love you I don't know
how long the while will be it rate this
particular episode very highly I mean
just really just pump this one up as
much as possible because all your
friends it would be funny to see John
get a complex about this this episode so
that would be funny
I mean it was better than any previous
episode of dear Hank and John and I
cannot imagine what that is except that
John is holding me back i I've been
saying this for years oh it's such a
such a clear truth thank you for
watching this thank you for listening so
thank you for shut up have you have you
ever watched John make a video because
this is how we do it
over and over and over again I was there
that pretty much the day John made his
first video oh wow
so imagine what that was like it took
him like six hours and he was crying for
three of those all right thank you all
for listening so much to this episode of
dear Hank and John but without John and
instead with Maureen Johnson and
remember like this one more like this
one more thank you we have an editor of
this podcast his name is Nicholas
Jenkins we have the theme music from
gunnarolla we have our special guest
Maureen Johnson who you can find on
Twitter I think it's just at Maureen
Johnson right yes it is and and I'm Hank
green this has been dear Hank and John
you can send us your questions at Hank
and John at gmail.com
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome